A lot of people would say you have got reason
more than most to hate sharks and yet you
don’t.
Can you explain it?
>> It was in a spear fishing championship
that I was the reigning champion.
It was a six hour competition.
After four hours many fish had been speared
and each one had bled into the water.
The tide had gone out, but nobody had seen
any sharks.
And I went out a bit wider and deeper to try
and find fish that hadn't been scared.
And as I dived down I was just about to spear
a fish when this thump and crash hit me in
the chest, knocked the gun out of my hand,
the mask off my face.
I was held through the water.
Then I realized it had to be a shark.
And I felt: What can I do to protect myself?
So I gouged the shark’s head over with my
fingers trying to get its eyes.
It seemed to let go and as it...
I fell away.
I pushed at that shark to try and push it
away.
But my hand went right in his mouth, ripping.
I ended up with only one tendon left and 94
stitches in my hand.
But I grabbed the shark around the belly and
still 30, 40 feet under water holding on and
then I realized air, because I was snorkeling
and I was going to drown.
I pushed up to the surface.
And on the surface I yelled out: Shark, shark.
And I looked down and the shark was coming
back to attack again.
I could see this great big head and white
teeth coming up through the blood red water
and I thought: I have got nothing at all to
protect myself.
I kicked at the shark.
But then a miracle happened.
The shark turned and swallowed the float that
I had attached two or three fish to.
It dived and as it dived it dragged me under
water and it...
I am on the rope.
And as it dragged down I tried to find my
belt to get rid of it, but I couldn’t find
it.
I couldn’t find the catch.
And I hadn't breathed... deep breathed much.
And I was just about to gasp water and drown
when another miracle happened.
The line broke.
It was severed when the shark bit me around
the chest and it managed to break.
As I came up to the surface yelling out: Shark,
shark, shark, a boat actually had seen the
bright red water, my blood, and was coming
over to investigate.
They quickly picked me up, rolled me into
the boat and with really great precision I
was in a hospital within an hour given blood
and luckily stitched up.
The photographs that were taken on the operating
table and my stories went around the world.
People wondered whether I would go back in
the water.
It was when I was at the Adelaide Zoo looking
at the lion cages that I came up with the
idea.
I will make a cage.
I will lower it over the side of the boat
in an area where these great big great white
sharks habit and I will have a look for myself
to see if I want to go diving again, because
I loved diving, but I was really scared.
We made the first cage and on that first expedition,
you know, 48 years ago, we made the first
great white shark films ever.
>> That firs time that you put the cage in
the water, did that cure your fear?
>> Not really at all.
It helped.
The first shark that came really looked like
a small submarine with a deadly front on it
like a torpedo to the teeth.
We thought maybe the sharks were interested
in the people inside.
But then we found that they would come up
an bite on the cage even when there was no
one in it and what we ended up finding it
was the electrolysis that was sent out by
the salt water on the seal that attracted
them.
>> And so now that you spend so much time
with sharks, I mean, how do you feel about
them?>>
They are a wonderful, interesting animal.
And even today they still need help, because
people still fear and dread them because they
are the last major predator that will eat
you.
But with education, it think people will understand
that we need them in our oceans and of 400
varieties, there is only a handful that may
bite people.
The more I got interested in sharks and the
more I loved the sea, I was able to return
and go abalone diving all around... along
our coastline.
I spent 16 years and 5000 hours or more underwater
and on those occasions I only saw three sharks.
Normally they don’t have humans on their
menu list.
They prefer to stick to their own food.
Thank goodness they didn’t, because along
our beaches they could ... there would be
a real smorgasbord if they wanted to.
>> A lot of people would say you have got
reason, more than most, to hate sharks and
yet you don’t.
Can you explain it?
>> It is the anomaly of this fear that was
generated and shown to me after my shark attack
made me think.
Going back into the water was a real relief
and I found it wasn’t as bad as everybody
thought.
So I spent the whole of my life trying to
put sharks in a different perspective.
>> Because of that experience you had.
>> Because of my experience, yes.